así que está muy buenos días pues lo
cierto es que la jornada de ayer está
era muy la gente estaba muy expectante
por lo que iba a pasar sin embargo horas
antes del aterrizaje del presidente de
donald también la casa blanca anunció
precisamente eso que el mandatario había
dado negativo a la prueba de coronavirus
y no suponía ningún riesgo el presidente
se dio un auténtico baño de masas aquí
en el aeropuerto de sanford en el centro
de florida y dijo precisamente la
importancia que tienen estados como
florida fue es realmente significativo
que hubiera escogido este estado
consciente de lo importante que es para
su reelección y es que los expertos
dicen que quien gane florida ganará las
elecciones de eeuu joe tiene programados
esta semana actos en pensilvania iowa y
carolina del norte georgia y florida
próximo destino de bailén por cierto
estos estados serán los que definirán la
elección antolín
pues sí hay que recordar que hay estados
que los denominados estados azules como
california en nueva york que
tradicionalmente votan demócratas global
y los los rojos como georgia kentucky
que es siempre tienden a votar a
republicano pero hay esos estados o
pendulares que son los que se están
enfocando a la ambas campañas a florida
es uno de ellos que por cierto es hoy el
candidato demócrata joe biden tiene
varios actos de campaña en el sur de la
florida pero también hay otros estados
que serían claves se necesitan 270 votos
electorales y esos estados que no se
definen porque quienes van a escoger es
si rojos o azules demócratas o
republicanos pues ambas campañas están
muy pendientes y ultimando apurando
estas últimas tres semanas de campaña
electoral para convencer a los indecisos